Let's see if we can tackle a motion problem together. Janet and Rohan agree to
meet at LAX, the Los Angeles airport. Janet's going to travel 250 miles, while
Rohan is going to travel 300 miles. If Rohan travels 20 miles faster than
Janet, and they both spend the same amount of time traveling let's see if we
can find Janet's speed. Now this looks like a complicated problem but we're
going to break it up into steps and see if we can tackle it together. Now for
any of these motion problems I think it's best to use a table. A table like
this helps us organize our information so we can figure out the distance, the
rate and the time for each of the objects. In this case we're wondering about
Janet's speed and Rohan's speed. So read through this problem and then when you
think you understand it try to identify what should be the variable. Which of
these amounts should be our variable so that way we can set up the right
expressions to begin solving our problem.